well let me tell you something and why i
asked you guys to come here today
because i do love the both of you we
gave george a bunch of photographs
and these photographs are of different
gentlemen hunky men
men from his generation and we wanted
him to evaluate these men here in fact
was the prep so everyone could hear this
was us telling george what we needed him
to do and he did have a few caveats so
you're asking me to
judge a book by its cover just by their
surface appearance without knowing their
personalities right their uh
intellectual capacity their
sense of humor yeah like for example you
might see a man say wow i have the
feeling that he would be great at all
liking the rambles
exactly exactly just the service
but brad was also kind enough to not be
in the room today so that you can feel
that you can
you can let your juices flow
so when you use this i
hope that you will include my caveats
here
what we didn't tell george in honor of
father's day these are pictures of our
staff's fathers
[Laughter]
[Music]
dad's bears oh you're so mean
oh you're so mean to keep me in
i thought you asked me to judge a book
by its cover george
is
you've got a beautiful body beautiful
[ __ ] you're a gorgeous man
all right it's time for george to rate
the staff dads we wanted to see how our
fathers would do so we gave pictures to
george the first father this happens to
be our wonderful kind producer jason
kaplan's nice father lovely man uh no
longer with us george shame on you
love my father so much i spent a lot of
yesterday missing him and thank you
wonderful thoughts i love you and you're
his son
you didn't tell me that you did george
george here you are here you are we
showed you a picture of jason's dad and
here is what your evaluation was well he
is fat to be blunt
anyone that's that slovenly
is an absolute turn off
i mean if in a bookstore i came across a
book and
that was on the cover
i would put it right down there and move
on on a scale of one to ten i would give
him a minus one
is a negative one
negative one
jason that is unfair
[Laughter]
i mean your father was such a lovely man
the salt of the earth uh such a cruel
evaluation a negative way i said i'm not
judging the character or the soul of the
man george he would be
he would um he would be rolling over in
his grave right now but he's too
slovenly
let's just say the first ad did not do
well unfuckable
unfuckable all right there we go
here is our second dad is your dad uh
still with us wolfie no he is deceased
you loved him very much
very much yep
well he's he's fleshy lots of flesh
he's got
tits breasts
rather than chest he's very hippie he
hasn't taken care of himself he's
let himself go to pot look at the
look at the tits on him he's getting the
big beginning of a
roll around the waistline
that bushy
mustache is not an attractive thing on
him
if i happen to walk into a room and see
this
picture of a guy
in his underwear
i would uh close the door and walk away
oh wow i would put him pretty much
around uh
at least he's a two he's not a negative
all right so wolfy's dad according to
george is unfuckable
dad
i i was presented these photos
praise them in terms of their sex appeal
that's right
this was not explained to me this was a
dishonest test
[Laughter]
it would be a good time to let you know
that brad was in on the bed he's known
for
[Laughter]
he kept it a weeks
he kept it a secret all right sal's dad
sal's dad who is a very macho let's see
how he did when george didn't know it
was sal's first of all he's got a
cigarette in his mouth i hate the smell
and certainly the taste of a smoker um
he's dressed um carelessly he um
looks
unbathed i say i don't trust you he's uh
suspicious
and distant he's attorney
i would rank him from one to ten
a uh a sagging three
close to two
unfuckable
[Laughter]
that's the term unfuckable
and that was the basis on which i was to
judge these photos
you made it very clear that sal's dad
was unfuckable
well i'll have you know in defense good
thing that your fathers are unfuckable
well i will say
these fathers produced
let me say something here i mean listen
in sal's father's defense he has [ __ ]
a lot of women in his life has all kinds
of illegitimate brothers and sisters
that he's just learning about so your
father did very well with what little he
had is that correct very very true i
mean yesterday was father's day i mean
we pretty much rented out the nights of
columbus for all the kids there
well you are blessed to have a father
that was
that produced you you are a nice guy you
are a decent guy yes you are a troubled
guy but you know
leave it up nice george please now let's
go to fun george do you feel that sal's
father is uh not attractive as well oh
my goodness i feel bamboozled after all
this i am a disgraced grand marshal
brad
get me my lawyer
and the blueberries
thank you fun george now
uh here is george salivating over young
will's father he looks like he might be
a runner he's got tight muscles a little
too bushy um beard
i don't like all that bushiness
but the face is interesting
interesting eyes
the lips look full but it's surrounded
by all that beard i would consider him
uh beyond this picture i would turn the
cover and start reading and feeling
i'd like to peel him as well as i hope
it's reciprocated
um brad and i call it wrestling it'd be
worth the a few tumbles
and then
working up some sweat
i'd
run my
lips over each tit
and with my tongue feel the nubs
work my way down the stomach muscles
further down
and
tease around there
and
let the
energy of
the body
build
the construction
until it's and edit this
and then
get a little taste just a teasing taste
and then get serious
i would give him an eight yes george was
very taken with young will's dad
will how would you feel with a new
stepfather
[Laughter]
were you proud that george has attracted
you know george is a superstar and he's
attracted to your father how did you i
wasn't surprised i thought he would be
uh george's type
pretty muscular dude he loves to run
around half naked all the time
still in great shape do you have any
nudes of your father weekend because
george george came all over the picture
robin i do have richard christie's dad
who surprisingly looks exactly like
richard he's in a military uniform i
don't remember what george had to say uh
he's all
clothed and military and frowning
probably a pessimist he's not
that particularly attractive
and he doesn't look uh inviting the
whole thing is it turned off he's a
complete turn off i'd rather jack off
than
it wouldn't even be sex
i mean it'd be difficult for me to get
get anything up for him
on a scale of one to ten i'd say he's a
four oh
gross dad
sorry
well how do you feel richard it's
horrible your father's the kindest man
i've ever i apologize i'm so sorry
richard thank you
i've danced naked for you george i've
seen you naked yeah richard
richard it must be it must have been
horribly hard for you to hear i know it
was hard when i heard about my dad yeah
yeah i love it i do i love my dad so
much we talked for a long time yesterday
for father's day but you know what after
hearing other dads being reviewed a four
is pretty good yes it is
i'll take it well uh we've come to the
end the only one left is uh mike
pearlman who's some considered the best
looking guy in our staff are you ready
for this or you brace for this do you
love your dad i love him i'm ready let's
see what he said he's got a nice smile
and the face looks uh well
shaped and formed uh a light must
mustache lush hairs
hair on his chest
he looks fairly trim i'd turn the page
and start reading the first page and i
probably would continue reading
yeah he's worth
looking into
i'd like to feel the whole face and
then i'd uh
roam over his face
and then neck
and then chest
my hands would be roaming all over his
body and
if there's similar reciprocation
i'd get even more
strongly involved
i'd hug him and
wrap my legs around him and
get much more muscular
on a scale of one to ten he would be a
nine i'd want to be all over him
wow wow well uh
let's just say george wants to [ __ ] your
dad
no that was not the rules of the game
well uh what a sexy evaluation of mike
perlman's dad mike how exciting do you
know george could be your stepfather
i mean listen it's you know it's uh
i don't know how to feel about that but
i guess on a strictly competitive level
i guess it's a win
right i didn't think anybody was going
to do better than will's dad
came in first well what we've learned
today on this father's day special that
uh george has been such a wonderful
judge he reminds me of simon cowell on
america's got talent literally mean
bitterly mean but what we learned is
i think we learned number one brad that
george wants a threesome with will and
his dad
but you know howard this is one example
when george did the reviews of these
pictures
he
never told me what he said in that room
and this is why i have to monitor him 24
7.
because he's a loose cannon
in honor of this bit and you being such
a good sport uh mike uh mike stad and
will's dad are here to blow you now
if brad will give
permission uh you say it's all right for
today it's fine
and what a wonderful tribute to fathers
everywhere
where you all are blessed with wonderful
fathers yes well what we've learned here
today howard is that if you aren't
one of those beautiful men
you'd better develop some other skills
right
as far as george
don't i know don't i know well how much
fun was that george
[Music]
oh
is
oh my
you've got a beautiful body beautiful
[ __ ] you're a gorgeous man